rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message do what you love
over to you Damon - how do you say
motivated not get burned out I only do
what I love you got to do what you love
you can't get burnt out and I do get
burnt out you know once I'm in a
business and I don't enjoy it no more
that's the thing I can't it's hard for
me to stay in the business for a long
period of time because the people tend
to make me sick so as soon as I start to
get aggravated you know it's like I'll
be on the Block if the block starts to
make me mad I go to another block even
if I got the block click and it's just
like I won't compromise my quality of
living you know what I'm saying but like
right now what I'm doing is you know I'm
building things that I could pass to my
kids but only things that I love and my
family so I love making movies I'll make
it movies I love it I don't think I'm
gonna be burnt out with that any time
soon you know and then also when you're
in the business of making money off
other people that person could make you
sick and you don't want to make money
off them no more so that's the reason
why I try to only make money off myself
these days and also do things that you
know my girl or my wife rocky if she's
inspired then we'll do that business I'm
like some revolving my children I like
that business but I worked hard to put
myself in that position so doing work
that you love is the number one rule
that keeps coming up over and over and
over again on this channel because
that's what successful people do it's in
the book the top ten was a success I
looked at 40 of the most popular people
we've ever profiled on the channel and
the number one rule they all have in
common is doing what you love
I love Dane Dash's approach and
especially when he's talking about
stress and burnout I think it's really
really really hard to get burnt out
doing work that you love it's possible
but it's really really really hard the
work that you love should energize you
I should fill you up not deplete you if
I think about median entrepreneurs to
help them with their business if I think
about coming here and making videos for
YouTube if you think about meeting Alex
to talk with TBS or meeting Lily to talk
about her business or if I'm getting
ready to speak at an event I would think
about those things that things that
really fill me up it gives me energy not
take away I've been filming here all day
and I've had a couple bars to eat I
haven't gone to the bathroom yet just
thinking about it makes me have to go to
the bathroom it's like I just go through
it because I love this work this isn't
work it fills me up where when you are
feeling super stressed out or feeling
burnt out it's typically from work that
you're not enjoying it's from all the
crap that you have to deal with in your
business that's what gets you anxious
can lead to depression can leads a lot
of unhappiness and so I like to use
stress as a good filter I like to use
burnout as a fantastic filter if you are
constantly burning yourself out then
chances are you're doing the wrong work
and I would look at my schedule look at
where I've spent my time today and how
much of that work that I actually love
probably not a lot if I'm feeling burnt
out at the end of the day and so how can
I make a plan to eliminate that work
from my life that may be something that
is immediate like no more I'm not gonna
do this anymore I'm just cutting this
off and I'm gonna go do something else
or it still may be required for your
business but you're making a transition
plan so you can eliminate yourself from
it whether that's in a year or six
months or three months you know as an
example for me and making these videos
editing was something that I could burn
out on I like editing at the beginning
just just to learn it just to learn the
new skill the techniques to understand
how the software work to be able to see
a video come up on screen like I edited
that I made that felt really nice then I
got used to it and then I got bored of
it and then I didn't want to learn
anymore in it and then it felt like a
chore I liked making the videos I didn't
like editing the videos and so I had to
make a plan to get an editor on board to
help me with this because this was
leading to anxiety and stress and
unhappiness in my life not to the point
where I'm burning out but to the point
where I'm not making enough great videos
for you guys because I was doing too
much work that I didn't like and you'll
never have success doing work that you
don't love you look at the people at the
top they love the work that they're
doing not every day again is amazing and
not every moment of every day is amazing
but net-net
they love what they're doing and so if
you're feeling that burnout if you're
feeling that stress I highly encourage
you to look at how your day was spent
what were the tasks what were the
responsibilities what they what were the
activities that led to you feeling
burnt out and then how can you either
immediately eliminate them from your
life or create a transition plan so that
in a week a month three months six
months whatever it is those things are
occupied and off to somebody else so the
question they today is I'm curious what
is the thing that leads to the most
burnout in your life or in your business
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to see what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout
out to Nick Francis Nick thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word taking my picture posting
it online
I really really appreciate the support
man and I hope you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event spresso
[Music]
don't know about trying to make what I
think people will like you know it I
think because it doesn't sound like
1/4000 from top to bottom people
disregard it because it's all over the
place people think it's messy or chaotic
but I think it's beautiful chaos and
it's perfect
then it's my favorite album to date
regardless of what anyone says and um I
can understand why people don't like it
it's different and sometimes different
doesn't equal good to some people but I
love it and you know that's great that's
all that matters I mean if you if you
make something you 100% love and
everyone loves it
that's a win-win that's great if you
have something that you really love and
everyone makes it at least you love it
and you just move on a very spiritual
person and I follow my spirit and I do
it my spirit tells me to do you know and
I don't have a set like oh I want to
play this type of character and I won't
play that type of character I'm
receptive to anything you know and when
the right thing comes along if it's
serious that was funny if it's silly if
it's low but see I'm but it put it this
way I do I just do whatever makes me I
get the most gratification from as an
artist you know I do music albums and
nobody buys my records I do them because
I love making music you know and that's
the same way I'm about movies I don't
make movies because I'm well I don't go
into it thinking let me do this because
then people are come or how much will
the movie make and I'm trying to make
the audience do that I do what feels
right for them you know I have tons of
things I'd like to do
and life is short unfortunately but I
hope it will be long enough for me to do
to do some of these I have known a few
writers who have retired
I cannot imagine ever retiring I did
writing and being a writer is too much
part of my identity and too much part of
what I am I don't know what I would do
with all that time if I did stop writing
you know play video games or something
like that watch a lot more television
that it seems unlikely to me I've always
told stories whether I could make my
living from it or even when I was a
little kid just making up stories for
the other kids in the neighborhood and I
think I'm gonna continue to do that
until the end if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be
collect a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details